hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my first agents of shield season 3
video they they pretty much said that
they're doing secret warriors in season
3 so I'm gonna explain some of the
changes they're making to the comics
because that was more of a Nick Fury
storyline and the TV show is gonna make
it more Phil Coulson if you've never
read secret warriors in the comics it's
actually a great storyline it was
written by Brian Michael Bendis and
Jonathan Hickman both really great
Marvel writers but it's mostly known as
being an amazing Nick Fury storyline so
if you're big Nick Fury fan from the
comics then check it out when most
people talk about it in the context of
the TV show they're talking about it
more as a daisy Johnson's storyline and
she was kind of point girl on Nick Fury
squad but but Nick Fury was the main
character of that storyline Nick Fury
has appeared on the TV show like we
didn't see him during season 1 it was it
was a big event thing but Phil Coulson
is proxy for most of the movie based
Avengers stuff originally in the comics
the reason Nick Fury put the secret
warriors together was in response to
Norman Osborn stark Avengers Norman
Osborn co-opted shield and the Avengers
in the wake of secret invasion in Dark
Reign this is way way back in the comics
this is after the scroll invasion Nick
Fury is on the outs so he sees what
Norman Osborn's doing and wants to
combat it he thinks that he should be in
charge not Norman Osborn so he puts his
super-powered team together and calls it
secret warriors dum-dum duggan from the
Howling Commandos was a big part of that
don't expect to see him on the TV show
anytime soon he just signed on to be
damian darhk-- on arrow season 4 so he's
gonna be way too busy with that to do
Marvel stuff for the most part what I'm
hoping the TV show does is they just
they double down on super-powered people
until Coulson recruits more people
though the only superpower people he has
are Lincoln in Skye those are his secret
warriors until until more people come on
the show but because Simmons got sucked
into the black obelisk I'm hoping that
means she's part inhuman so she gets to
be part of secret warriors and she
manifests um subscribe our in case there
was any doubt about Simmons coming back
like she has been prominently featured
and all the stuff that people have been
posting on social media behind the show
so she is definitely coming back the
real question is is where did she go and
what's she gonna be like when she comes
back the Simmons character is an
original creation of the show so I don't
think she's going to become anyone from
the Cobb
but they might give for some sort of
inhuman ability in the same way that
characters on the flash just found out
that their metahumans Cisco and Caitlin
just found out that they were metahumans
at the end of last season - the flash
but they haven't really explained how
those powers are gonna manifest so if
you're watching both shows just expect
the same type of transformation for both
characters like Simmons will probably
still look like Simmons she might just
get some abilities that will help her in
her scientific endeavors usually when
characters on superhero shows get
superpowers it's something that enhances
what they already do unless they're
taking the character in a dramatically
different direction like if they turn
Simmons into she-hulk I would I would
shout with joy but I'm not expecting
something like that I'm not even spectin
that kind of a left turn
that's such a good question if they are
gonna give Simmons special powers what
do you want her in human abilities to be
Theophilus totally would not have sucked
her in if she did not have inhuman DNA
in her there's actually this really
interesting meta thing going on with
secret warriors because you know agents
of shield is going full-bore with the
super-powered team but agent Carter also
had a little interaction too when they
invoked Leviathan in the comics they get
tied up with the secret warriors
storyline they start using a lot of
alien tech so it gets it gets really
weird
and obviously agent Carter didn't go in
that direction it was it was kind of a
disappointment I haven't done any agent
Carter videos for season 2 yet but they
are doing more comic-book specific stuff
that they're taking the show like agent
Carter herself Hayley Atwell his
character is going to Los Angeles with
Jarvis
so like the show itself like the
location where they shoot it is gonna
look a lot different that's not gonna
premiere to early next year in January
or like right around the same time so
I'm gonna do videos when it gets a
little closer to that I feel like when
it comes to agents of shield or like the
TV show people really just want to know
like what comic book stuff they're gonna
do like you know how is this gonna
crossover with Captain America Civil War
how a secret warriors gonna get involved
with that hopefully we will see some
interaction between Civil War and the
secret warriors
just because Secret Invasion Norman
Osborn taking over a shield from Nick
Fury all that stuff happened in the wake
of Civil War in the comics
I mean don't don't expect a whole lot of
agents of shield characters to appear in
the movies anytime soon but it would be
awesome to see them at least reference
the team this years age of Ultron
crossover was like the weakest thing
ever it was
crossover at all so I feel like they
need to double down and since Winter
Soldier was like such a shield based
movie I feel like it's easier for them
to do shield stuff in civil war but
here's just like a really cool list of
some of the characters that were part of
the secret warriors team with some of
their powers hopefully they'll do him on
the TV show there was Alexander Aaron
he's the son of Ares he has powered a
lot like Hercules you know he's part
human part God so he has limited
abilities of precognition
I mean Hercules has strength he can
manifest even more godlike powers but he
can only tap into them once his mortal
body dies I do like that idea Buffy the
Vampire Slayer kind of played with that
mythology a little bit I think it was
angel where a character died but then
they came back manifesting amazing
powers they're a bunch of magic based
characters too you know obviously magic
being a little bit different from the
power you find in gods there was
sebastian druid who's the son of doctor
druid JT james codename hellfire he's
the grandson of phantom Rider
he ends up being like a double agent for
Hydra he can charge weapons with fire
like he has a chain that he charges with
fire and swings around very ghostrider
esque and then there's a character named
Eden who has reality-warping powers that
that might be a little too much for the
TV show the TV shows
try not to introduce like too many
overpowered characters and when you can
warp reality it's kind of like a game
changer if they did something like that
on the TV show they might try to make it
look a little like scarlet witch's chaos
magic
although she really didn't do that much
chaos magic during Avengers age of
Ultron I think when it comes to magic
we're not gonna see a whole lot of
characters on the TV shows until we get
Doctor Strange the movie I think they're
targeting that is the beginning of magic
in the Marvel Universe even though when
you think about it like it exists now
like Doctor Strange has been around for
a long time in the Marvel Universe we
just have a meta mute it's just
typically that that's the way things
flow downstream it's like you know they
start in the movies and then they
trickle down to the TV shows the recent
exception to that though has been the
Inhumans they introduced the idea of the
Inhumans on agents of shield before we
saw it in the movies Baron von Strucker
kind of teased it at the end of Winter
Soldier but he didn't say the name
Inhumans he just called it the age of
miracles so it was like their powers
could a bit could have come from
anywhere
Kevin Feige could have totally made the
executive decision to
change his mind about doing Inhumans in
the movies and said their powers came
from somewhere else that's usually the
way Marvel leaves itself loopholes like
we don't know what we're gonna do yet so
we're just gonna be as vague as possible
about where this stuff comes from like
they didn't reveal that Loki's scepter
had the mind gem in it till age of
Ultron
even though fans theorized that right
after that first Avengers movie came out
in case you don't know agents of shield
season 3 is gonna premiere September
29th it's still gonna be a Tuesday night
show so I'll still be doing videos it'll
actually it'll start before arrow in the
flash and stuff so they're not gonna
bump up against each other so it'll be
like shield every Tuesday night for a
couple weeks till arrow and the flash
start and then I'll kind of move my
schedule around a little bit
they have been shooting episodes but
they haven't been releasing a lot of
behind-the-scenes stuff not nearly as
much as like the arrow flash people have
and if I haven't mentioned it yet or I
didn't mention it in in my season 2
finale videos Ward is the new Big Bad I
mean I mean they'll have more villains
it's a 22 episode season there'll be a
ton more villains but he is assembling a
team like an evil secret warriors team
around him I say secret warriors but
he's just assembling a team we have no
idea if he's gonna find superpower
people and try to co-opt them I'm gonna
withhold some judgment on Ward as big
bad until I see some footage of him I
feel like his acting in season 2 was a
little hammy when he was trying to be
evil it's a little bit better when he's
trying to be ambiguous like the really
creepy scenes that he had with agent 33
like when they when he was pretending or
maybe not pretending to be in love with
her those were kind of fun to watch just
because they were so creepy so he does
creepy well but I don't know about
outright evil you guys can let me know
though like what were your favorite Ward
scenes from season 2 like what kind of
situations do you feel like his
character works best in if he like him
going into evil Nick Fury mode like like
in the battlefield
full man of action will be like the best
possible scenario he he doesn't do quite
so well like I feel like it's not quite
as much fun when he's just being an
to someone like when he's just
messing with Skye's mind if you want a
really good example of an actor that
does that kind of dialogue really well
look at Tom Cavanagh in the last couple
of episodes of the flash season one like
once they have him behind bars when he
starts to mess with Cisco's mind Tom
Cavanagh much
more compelling villain than Brett
Dalton that I look forward to him
proving me wrong on agents of shield I
mean we'll see
Tom Cavanagh is hard to beat you can't
beat the reverse-flash
it's in his pitch I always win I just I
love how he says that to Barry
no matter what happens I always win I've
been all across time and space I always
beat you so there are a couple big
things that I'm spinning the wheels up
on so I've got some Suicide Squad stuff
that'll happen later this week VidCon is
happening so I'm trying to plan some
videos around that I've got some Doctor
Who coming up so be sure to subscribe to
get everything
there's I would say like the end of
August is really like when TV comes back
so we'll try and get prepared for like
all the really cool stuff that's coming
in the next week or so
well you guys wait for all that stuff to
drop you can click here to learn all
about mr. terrific in the comics and how
he's coming on arrow season 4 and you
can click here for my ant-man Easter egg
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you